son visage est connu de tous les fans de
la nba et evan fournier joueurs du magic
d'orlando et de l'équipe de france a
traversé l'atlantique pour inaugurer le
quatrième obscur leur de france à
carrières sous poissy équipement doté de
deux mini terrain de basket en indoor
pour que les joueurs puissent
s'affronter en 3 contre 3 ça me fait
super plaisir
voilà c'est un projet qui me tient à
coeur depuis longtemps et quand tu es
gamin tu as vraiment de choix soit joué
en club soit joué sur les plus grandes
et donc voilà ça c'est une alternative
un petit peu différente et
c'est peut-être pour ça que j'ai mal au
genou maintenance parce que je veux sur
la plus grosse maj alès et donc si
l'abonné ce genre de terrain je
regarderai le sportif de 25 ans
originaire du val-de-marne a également
profité de cet événement pour rencontrer
des jeunes du club de basket de
magnanville il est très bon et ouais il
est un bail les gens qui il accepte de
prendre des photos avec nous donc c'est
cool
l'hormadi way ligue n'augure à sion 2 ou
factory corner la savait qu'ils allaient
avoir qu'une personnalité que ce soit
une bille mêmes proies même problème une
légende et on m'a dit ah veille allait
avoir évolué fournier ça m'a fait un
choc et dès que j'ai vu dès que le mot
que j'ai dit bonjour ça ça m'a fait
bizarre et joue en équipe de france
il joue dans une grande équipe aux états
unis et enfin c'est impressionnant de le
voir parce qu'il est comme grand il est
balèze est juste de le voir dans un bon
jour 2 le ticket c'est impressionnant
avec evan fournier comme pareil avec ces
nouvelles infrastructures flambant neuf
le oups quand l'heure de carrières sous
poissy espère attirer plusieurs
centaines de clients chaque mois pour
dribbler sur ces terrains les joueurs
devront débourser entre 40 et 50 euros
pour une heure